du poivre fraîchement moulu ajoute la
touche finale un plat le moudre avec un
beau moulin se fait en un tour de main
et parfois du bout des doigts
nous avons mis à l'essai 18 moulin dont
trois modèles électriques et il me des
classiques là que bien des gens
connaissent le modèle qu'on va tourner
et qu'on souhaite ajuster avec avec
davis depuis quelques années on a vu des
modèles apparaissent
on a des ajustements qui sont par en
dessous on a aussi les fameux et moulay
manivelle on ne voulait essayer parce
qu'on voulait savoir aussi certaines
personnes il faut avoir des problèmes de
motricité fine ou l'arthrite
on élimine électrique je vais tout de
suite texans ont tous gourmand au niveau
des piles un peu beaucoup à mon goût et
on a deux modèles ici à piston les
moulins ont des mécanismes fait d'acier
d'acier inoxydable d'acier carbone ou de
céramique
si on veut quelque chose qui va être
durable on peut opter soit pour du
carbone qui est un alliage qu'il allait
le métal le plus dur sur le marché ce
qu'on trouve c'est de l'acier régulier
qui est pas mauvais mais éventuellement
va finir par se brûler ou la céramique
les avantages à céramique c'est qu'on
peut mettre ou du poivre ou du seul dans
le moulin parce que le seul enjeu
mouline métal va freiner par curgies de
métal afin de moudre le poivre des
granulométries différentes
traditionnellement l'ajustement se fait
par les coûts de fermeture du réservoir
comme c'est le cas avec les modèles de
ricardo flatteuse mais et trudeau
trudeau a vraiment garder le côté vice
ajustable sur le dessus donc faut faire
attention quand on décide du niveau de
grosseur de grains ce souhait que la vie
va passer dévissé alors on a les
fenêtres chaumières américain et est
ajustée avec la ville bien différent
celui là c'est qu'une espèce de
marchands en nylon dentelée qui empêche
la vis de de trop tourner dans le sens
inverse
certains modèles sa juste part les coûts
de retenue du mécanisme en céramique
sous le moulin
comme le paternot ou le starfrit ce
système garde bien sa position mais une
mouture très fine et plus difficile à
obtenir
enfin certaines marques comme oxo cours
de médecine et peugeot offre n'a
justement par une bague graduée à la
base du moulin depuis plusieurs années
maintenant peugeot a décidé de mettre de
côté le système de vista justement par
là dessus donc entre le système ou
select
donc on a juste à la base indécis c'est
justement qu'on veut on faire attention
de ne pas mettre la mettre au trou il ya
me cadres alors justement parce qu'on va
avoir tendance à bouger avec nos mains
puis la vie ce qu'on a sur le dessus
bien uniquement à donner accès aux
réserves pour le remplir justement quand
vient le temps de remplir le réservoir
l'orifice et souvent viennent et 3 mais
certains modèles rendre la tâche plus
facile soit par une grande ouverture ou
un accès plus facile et ceci à manivelle
offre en principe un avantage quand à la
manipulation
le gros problème c'est au niveau du
travail on dirait que parce qu'une
monnaie trop petit on n'est pas
nécessairement la stabilité dans quatre
tentes ont travaillé comme l'un des fois
ça bloque des fois ça de l'autre port
dans le cadre du tri douaniers en
nettement la judée c'est probablement
celui qui m'a le plus impressionné dans
la gamme lorsque en partant du principe
que le même système de meule qui est
ajustable sur le dessus quand on parle
de facilité d'opération je dirais la
garde et le franchement avec très très
peu d'effets ans j'arrive à faire nos
bords poivre
regardons maintenant comment performe
les moulins électrique alors ça veut
dire il faut un bon travail les trois
sont très gourmands au niveau des piles
tous les moulins électrique
je dirais sur le marché la plupart sont
équipés de petites lumières de six
cantons ont vu moudre ce qui est parfait
pour le super amoureux est un ennemi ans
ont baissé et peugeot 0 effarant c'est
vraiment juste par contact au niveau du
6 km touchscreen si vous voulez très peu
bruyant bémol tout ça c'est le système
électrique
le réservoir c'est ce que vous voyez
trudeau puisqu'on a offert aux enfants
c'est juste
comme un espèce de d'interrupteurs par
gravité qui ne fait que démarrer avec le
bien ça brise la magie 1.4 l appel ouais
donc lui aussi six 6 piles puis comme
vous pouvez voir les réservoirs mais
aussi et en plus j'ai à chaque fois que
genou j'ai pas de le briser
tout le système est comme ça et le
réservoir c'est vraiment que celui ci si
vous voulez offrir la discrétion du
peugeot électrique
vous devrez délier les cordons de votre
bourse puisqu'il se détaille à 130
dollars
sinon les trudeau et inc et une plus
brillants sont plus abordables à éviter
malgré leur prix alléchants les petits
moulins à piston qui n'ont pratiquement
pas de rendement et le cas mais ce thème
qui malgré un ajustement n'offrent pas
de différence de granulométrie est quand
même assez difficile au niveau de la
manipulation des fois il ya du poivre
des fois on n'a pas partir du principe
que une fois qu'on a passé à travers la
gamme le côté esthétique c'est à chacun
soit au boul
moi je prie toujours pour des moulins en
bois opaque
donc je n'ai jamais dans l'acrylique
transparent parce qu'on veut pas que le
point soit affectée par la lumière
bon là je mange bien je me retire tout
de suite après parce que je vous ai dis
pas d'acrylique mais celui là quand même
vraiment impressionné s'ils étaient
opaques
j'achète ça c'est sûr en résumé fletcher
ce serait mon premier livre avec peugeot
et peut-être ex aequo avec ricardo et le
trudeau à manuel mention spéciale à
changer oui évidemment cette période de
distanciation si je veux vous en ferez
du poids puis reste à distance
raisonnable j'aurais tendance à les
utiliser celui-ci
oui on est à deux matches
[Rires]